this is cool McDonald's flipped its
iconic M logo upside down to form double
use this is this is an actual McDonald's
sign which is a cool thing yeah yeah
that's neat kind of a neat creative way
for a major company to you know
commemorate International Women's Day
yeah well it turns out a lot of other
major brands are trying the same thing
they're trying to honor women by
changing their logos some are doing it
better than others I don't know for
example after today only the restaurant
chain Hooters will change its name to
life-giving breasts yeah that's their
new get this the the brawny towel guy
now is wearing a pink [ __ ] power hat
yeah del Taco is serving tacos stuffed
inside copies of The Feminine Mystique
by Betty banana yeah yeah the clothing
store the gap yeah is changing its name
to there's still a shocking gap in
women's pay
the iconic sneaker Air Jordans will now
be called share Jordans just for today
okay that is so lazy you can see the
tape just for one day yeah just for one
day
and finally Longhorns Steakhouse is
going to keep its name but they're
training the steer into a uterus and
fallopian tube
[Applause]
you